oh I'm Doug Walker this is me that's me
I am you you are me I am you I mean me
for five points if you know what movie
that's from uh not many me that I am you
but never mind okay so this is uh okay
bad that's a big clue if you well not if
you haven't seen the movie I can see
that they had no clue what they are but
you should see it anyway uh regardless
um this is a new section we sort of want
to try out cuz a lot of people when we
do in this - Creek review they're like
well how much of your real opinions is
in there and stuff and it's just what
ends really yeah I mean sometimes it's
like oh we try to ban movies so they're
not particularly good but sometimes I
don't know we like a movie more then
we're probably letting on and other
times we've done a movie where the
reviews has been yeah this sucks but
deep down inside it heard us on a very
visceral level and uh one of the things
with that I think is that they asked you
know well is is that what you really
think are you really that angry you
should I'm not quite that angry like I
can really hate a movie but it's not
like you know god damn you humanity or
something like that there's there's like
depends yeah there's like you so uh and
on top of that it's usually me in front
of the screen and you know Rob's well
the writers but he doesn't always get
you know a fair share and there's a lot
of times where you can really go into
detail try to get exactly what I deserve
sir and there's a lot of times we can
really go into details about these
movies so we're doing this section now
about our honest thoughts about a film
so Sophie's Choice yeah so what a hack
film sheesh downer um oh is a comedy
would be the darkest comedy of all time
so yeah this is a new section we're
starting where we're gonna do one right
now on the matrix and then the next
one's gonna be Mamma Mia cuz I know you
have things to say much more than I have
to say about that like that's actually
what it is like top three hated movies
you had to review included number two
yeah number two there you go so
definitely tune it for that there's
gonna be a lot of hate for that but uh
uh you may just be me shouting like dog
I don't know
so uh but we're gonna do our honest
views on on some movies we've reviewed
and if you have any that you want us to
talk about designed to be in a
particular order go ahead and mention it
below uh and we're gonna start off with
the matrix cuz this is the one that
people clearly have no strong opinions
about at all um we were doing that we
could have done manastir right I think
not a CEO who's got a better reception
than like in terms of like you go it's
honestly online I found the number of
people just like oh yeah this movie
always sucked and I'm like oh really I
know you know what I found and this this
is kind of fun that Falco since we've
gone back on YouTube I compared like our
website and then what YouTube thinks and
it's almost always polar opposite it
doesn't mean like what's right what's
wrong or once Martin wants to but it
just goes back and forth sometimes on
YouTube they're like but I like this
movie and other times on YouTube they're
like you're totally right this movie
sucks well on our site they're like how
dare you yeah no you can never tell so
with the matrix on our site people seem
yeah was you know we've all look bad got
pretty dated and silly and stuff like
that and YouTube it's like you can't
stock a car
you should talk about the sequel and I
did and they only got half the amount
that the matrix cut which is always they
already know those suck yeah maybe so I
don't know but whenever like how can you
talk about it well first of all it gets
really good views but that's not the
reason the reason really was that well
if years how many action I got here's
the thing if you've commented on it
you've already clicked on the video
which means that that was just views for
our so that's why don't be you know this
people you know like it was like why
would you even bother well you're
commenting and asking us and that just
gave us a but there's people come out
but I've watched it five times now and I
still I'm so dance like a guy
oh no so but so the views have really
been like on our website it's been like
you know pretty yeah I can see that even
people are like I kinda like it still
but whatever and then YouTube they're
like matters how I'm not going to take
it anymore
uh so this is a chance to talk about our
real views on it um like when I saw it
in the theater the first thing
jumped out to me really about a like
apart from the effects and everything is
that it was so bizarre how the first
half was almost nothing but talk and the
second half was nothing but action and I
found that really distracting I thought
they could balance it out a little bit
but it didn't destroy anything for me I
just thought it was a little full of
itself a little pretentious but fun you
know like you know the abused it way
more than I did when I saw it I just
liked it yeah I mean but but that's what
I that's what I mean like you serve what
dancing that's fun you know thank you
movie like Alfie you got like sucked in
like you know what's next what's in the
world went that blew my mind that look
at this no there were there were parts
of it that really sucked me but I didn't
think there was ever gonna be a sequel
mm-hmm so I just took it at face value I
wasn't sucked into the world so much cuz
there wasn't much to get sucked into
it's just like oh there's a matrix so
there's this fake world and then there's
the real world and the real world sucks
and the matrix is actually the
interesting part and I I like the idea
and then it ended with neo flying off
into space like Silver Surfer and I'm
like okay there it is like the end and
you know what's that could open up
what's it gonna mean and but then that
turned into a huge hit and they said are
and well we got less we got a few cool
scenes and reloaded but sometimes less
is more and sometimes more is less yes
revolution is definitely pretty bad but
let's most people know what we think of
the sequels will keep it mostly the
first one um you know the idea there
being another world you know that we're
not aware of and you know everything
kind of being symbolic and stuff like
that it's like this sci-fi has done this
before a dark City I think did it a bit
more effectively um but I didn't bother
me too much really I think they were so
close together that they they were in
their own bubble I I don't feel like oh
yeah the rip oh no I don't feel that you
know no I matrix is probably in
production right when Dark City already
came out well and again it's an idea
that's been done a lot that our reality
is an illusion just you know it's
spoiler a lot of films and stories have
done in the strengths of both dark city
and the first matrix versus the Matrix
sequels is it new not too
/ talk about it oh I don't know matrix
still had a lot Mary we're watching
they're like they talk a lot now Uncle
Bob buzz compared to the sequels it's
still coming about as equals yeah it's
like whoa okay we think it even a some
folk we've given you an idea of what
this all means but they didn't pick it
the hell apart you know Dark City did it
even less I mean dark section II was
very vague which I like dark cities is
almost like a Star Trek episode where
it's just like you know you were
searching for here and it's really in
here human yeah no and the matrix talked
to death about it but it you know it
knew how not to really overstay its
welcome as much as the sequels did like
it gave you just enough that you're like
oh well I can ask questions of my own
watching this and then the next two
films just proceeded to just answer a
whole bunch of questions I was like I
didn't need to know the answers of it I
want to figure out the answers for my
damn self well I think you brought up a
great point something I really like more
dark say than the matrix of the matrix
touched upon is that it does allow you
instead of shoving all this thing
answers answers answers it's saying you
know it's saying what about these
questions have you asked these questions
if you consider these questions and
that's why I like dark City a little bit
more because it is a little bit more
vague uh and I do like the style of
darks a more - but uh you know the fun
thing about matrix is that everyone's
like a lot of people say it was a very
nitpicky review and you know this at
some points are right it's like okay I'm
doing this for comedy and such but for
me the real Big E is the long-winded
speeches which don't kill the film
really you kind of go okay because this
was that this is at a point when action
films were just starting to be like hey
maybe we can think because we really
think about Phil even though I love a
lot of action films before we think
about the 80s and like the early 90s and
stuff it was not a thinking man's medium
you know you could argue even today it's
not necessarily but there's an option
now and I think because of that the long
wind in this gets to me a bit but the
big thing is that the two leads are so
boring you know and I never got no and I
okay here's the thing it well it's the
journey of the hero fair enough
Luke Skywalker has to learn stuff not
only physically but emotionally with uh
with the matrix everything's a plugin so
he's like I know kungfu show me okay he
knows kung fu
what Manos agree with you know what
philosophical changes did he have to
really go through aside from I know it's
the matrix okay you're missing something
done it's the only part one I don't
think it's actually a hero's journey as
much in part when there's a hero's
journey I talked about how he's the one
you're the Saviour though you're the one
who'll bring balance it but what has he
done what is it about him that's not
about if you look at it I don't think
it's really about him like he is just
it's really watching it's more about
Morpheus if I wanted to be a lot more it
was really about more yet I don't think
you can highwaymen he's not the one the
climax at the end he's not the one
saving the world
if I he's the one that has to be saved
but it's Morpheus is the one who has to
have faith that this clown they picked
up on you know it's not him on the front
of the poster it's always him in the
background he is not the focus you know
Keanu Reeves as if I'm saying if you
want to say it's a hero's journey thing
all three of them together yes cuz
that's where they start bringing the
shit and where he becomes literally this
messianic character but it's really very
simple like deceptively simple in the
first one it's here is this object that
Morpheus who is the only and the other
characters really um was it cypher the
Judas character Oh Judas yeah John Judas
I can't tell you Judas Italian Judas
valiant fugitive Judas
it's really about their reactions to
finding this guy and then having faith
in him Luke Skywalker did way more I
think in the original Star Wars that was
more like a cut-and-dry hero's journey
thing now they do that in the sequels
and develop it there but for me it's
like the first one Neil's just this guy
and you're right they do just throw it
at him and everything but to me that's
because it's not really was about the
hero's journey like he's not even the
most interesting character I don't know
sometimes
and every man that you just throw a
window I guess that's always the case
with Luke Skywalker - but no but I will
say that it's obviously we're trying to
go for the every guy you know like this
could be you anyone can be you know is
something great you know they're not
that's not if it really was about the
hero's journey then Morpheus probably
should have been dead by the end of the
first movie he never loses his sword
master
you know like Luke loses obi-wan or
something doesn't work on a word what
I'm saying well but if you're gonna use
the hero's journey archetype I don't
think it's that I don't say they follow
it I don't know an example yeah you just
have much of a character either it
doesn't mean it's you know well this one
had a lot of character - and this didn't
so clearly it's not dark at I think it
is they just didn't do it very well
I think you can watch it most of the
investment comes for Morpheus um I will
say this out of all the characters you
know Smith is just fun - way Hugo
Weaving is just fun to watch uh and
Morpheus is the only one where I'm like
oh I hope he doesn't die like I like
because he knows what he's talking about
he's pretty badass he actually does have
a character he even has an arc when you
think about it like his faith is kind of
challenged and so forth you know much
more than neo does my point no but he's
not he's not the main character he's not
you know at the very end it's not
Morpheus and Hugo Weaving having the
fight it's neo and and who comes out of
that movie and says you may want a B neo
because you can do the kung-fu but who
comes out of that movie and says yeah
that's the guy like nobody everybody you
think of Morpheus hell you even think a
Trinity more she's more in charge
through half Advil but that's my point I
think even though it's supposed to be
like he's learning and becoming strong
and everything like a like heroes
journeys stories uh we never really see
much of the learning and multi-part Lee
you never see the emotional impact I
think at the most when they come back
he's like you know that place have
really good noodles and even though we
kind of made fun of it I know what they
were doing they're trying to do like oh
like he's now that he's back in here he
sees it different and the world looks a
little different it's like fair enough
but the rest is all kung fu and just him
fighting and saying wait oh we should go
save him and that's about it you know
everything else is
the kung-fu so so in your opinion you
think the main character of the movie is
Morpheus yeah to a certain extent do you
think they have that line I don't know
if they had that in mind but that's what
it comes off as this is kind of like
your theory that the main character lore
the Rings is not Frodo but it's Sam oh
Christ it's not Frodo
good lord no Sam's the Sam is the one
that is the anchor of that story
Frodo's just the dude carrying the ring
oh no I'm not disagreeing yet I say you
know trying to give context here yeah I
mean by the end of it Frodo collapses
and Sam like lifts him up and he's like
I got this he carries him to the
mountain like it's really raining Frodo
kinda looks at her she's got it's like
you know known if you read the book it's
the same thing a lot of people will say
flat out their favorite character is Sam
hmm or Gandolfi you know but yeah I
think if you really look at it the main
character that happens a lot in stories
like you'll find that supposedly the
secondary character ends up kind of
being the main character now I'm not
sure that works throughout the whole
trilogy which is why I'm saying if you
look at the trilogy as a whole and count
the sequels into it you can say hero's
journey but if you're looking at the
first room as a standalone film which it
was it's not as much of a hero's journey
as star wars which was also a standalone
film we look at Empire and Jedi or
whatever but like when you look at the
Star Wars it's like that could have
ended with that award yeah even just
like it could have ended and should have
in the matrix's case with neo taking off
you know that was the point it's about
Morpheus finding this guy and saying you
you are the one I was looking for you're
the one I have faith in you all of you
other guys you have to have faith that
this idiot I found is the right idiot
and in the end what happens he says I'm
gonna go free everybody and does it
Morpheus is quest in the first movie at
least is complete and then they dragged
it on through to see okay I will say
this though with cuz I if the movie was
about Morpheus and neo was really more
of like the side character I would
probably like that more I probably enjoy
it more um but at the same time I mean
that the only example can be here right
now
maybe wicked where it's like we're
looking at the point of view is somebody
different where the main character
Dorothy from before is etching now a
side character or even the good which is
now a side character that is clearly no
question whatsoever the which is the
main character in that we're in that you
know the focus is on her even though
there's other important characters going
on we're in this one the focus clearly
isn't entirely on Morpheus it's more on
neo you know Morpheus I don't even think
comes in into like the end of the first
third like technically well but he's
talking to him the whole time Eli go
here do this which is its own set of
problems because I think when I was
watching it I was pointing it I was like
how can these computer programs miss
Neos yeah the cubical wall and I'm like
they're programs in this but how do you
do that like if your computer program
shouldn't you just have a system where
you're just like well they're plugged
into the matrix why do you even need to
physically find this guy if you can
rewrite the program because she says oh
you know when you see glitches and this
man you think it's a ghost that's really
the matrix rewriting itself in doing
that then why don't you just pull the
plug on neo rewrite the program so we
never existed within the matrix and
everybody else goes on like not giving a
shit well and this is kind of a problem
with it - is that cuz a lot of people
say well your nitpick you read too much
how come you didn't question this in you
know stuff like this in the dark night
or something land which first of all I
did but I did - yeah no but but it
didn't ruin anything for me because the
emotional focus was always there and I
think even people that like the matrix
are like know emotionally there's
nothing there
I mean it's it's cool ideas which they
are it's cool really groundbreaking
effects in action um but additionally
you're you not invested I mean even like
died her fans are only emotionally
invested in the way that Keanu Reeves is
character is an everyman and oh he's
like a blanks it's way you bro you -
yeah and he's like a blank slate Harry
Potter gives you some cell for you yeah
but I mean Harry Potter - you know what
I mean it is Harry Potter's syndrome
though this predated Harry Potter by
about a year I think so but I
I don't know I don't think I just like
the movie anywhere near as much as you
did I like when I first saw it I thought
it was okay and the more I admit it
could be the hype I do like a whole
editorial about the Mo's doesn't stick
I'll see it could be the way everybody
was so insulted what I would just say
yeah I never did much me I mean like
every buckin Dante Basco everybody's
like really I don't know just like what
are you and that's always we look at God
I got just so sick of it I'm gonna have
to go off fireball I just got so sick of
it you know I felt like you know what
it's not that great a film I'm sorry it
rates its up it's not that great a blah
blah blah and really I think was I don't
know and everything like it's you know
but there's all asset Ilocos always
feels like that some films just work on
ideas you know sometimes you just don't
get the complete package yes you're not
as emotionally invested but there is an
interesting conceit no that to that film
that nobody ever really talks about
witches they're all in a soulless
computer program and have been raised in
this computer program from day one I
always looked at it like this of course
they would talk like that of course they
would have no emotion they've all been
being run by computer programs for the
bulk of their lives but the computer
programs are more interesting than them
like all the computers have more
interesting will that's now that's a
failure of the see no no even the first
one the Oracle exactly times more
interesting Hugo Weaving is a million
times more interesting like half of
those agents yeah here's the thing Hugo
Weaving is only interesting because he's
chewing scenery they don't get along I
don't get much emotion out of him really
and the crazy crazy until the sequels
with no no kamae it's like I need to
leave I because even though I'm computer
I have want now which is explaining the
Animatrix now yeah that's a whole lot of
what okay but what emotion is there it's
really all coming out through the acting
I think what your issue is is the acting
no no he says you know I want out want
you know or I am I'm done with this
place and that's late that's because
he's a virus and had that I will say
this I thought that was an interesting
part of the movie which is this idea
that these humans being raised in this
computer program are all kind of
soulless and all talk like they're in a
Shyamalan film which is another thing
I'll say it had the advantage
of coming at a time when this Shyamalan
style of acting wasn't as fucking
annoying as it is now he doesn't have 20
of these films in a row where you're
just like use a contraction have an
emotion
dear God now with avatar now with like
the last airbender movie and all of
these Shyamalan films and oil films that
one sit on the known films to a degree I
you never saw your seller is but now
with with all of that we can kind of
look at me like oh my god I'm sick of
this but at the time like I was like
okay it's actually kind of a museum not
these you know Keanu Reeves go whoa and
like that now it's worn out its welcome
so I'm wondering if some of this is in
hindsight because at the time I thought
it was kind of cool no I there is some
truth to that where it's like a lab is
talking like I said it didn't now you
see it everywhere with the Nolan films
and stuff like that and it's not
entirely bad cuz it's like what are you
against people being smart or learning
something in the film or philosophical
of no please tell your smart it's that
there's no much no no but I mean even
films after the matrix it's more that
film is still a visual medium saying
only what needs to be said yeah the same
image is going to stick when I saw the
imitation game and Cumberbatch's
performance had a lot more emotion in it
and he's a super genius who's also
socially awkward so it can be done you
know what I think happened I think
somewhere and I think you can thank
slash blame the matrix for this the
films being made with these comic book
movies and stuff the ones that are very
long-winded Sully became analysis of the
film
you're watching while also being the
oh Christ you can throw unbreakable in
that list too yeah you can't wait this
isn't a comic book movie it's about
comic book movies I don't know no I do
just watch us make a comic book movie
that's interesting no there's a lot of
there's a lot you to that um and uh and
somewhere we got all on this line where
I think because for so long we are you
know and I I enjoy blade as a comic book
movie but it's also the blade syndrome
of its style over substance to the point
well it's just cooler if they have no
motion and wear sunglasses and all
leather and don't say much of anything
and it
it's the way honestly it's the Western
it's the Western archetype Clint
Eastwood walking around with two lines
of dialogue which is why maybe I don't
mind it as much I mind it when they
start then spouting off reams and reams
of dialogue because I'm just like now
what makes characters like that cool is
they don't talk yeah yeah no I'm totally
with the know but I didn't mind it as
much in the matrix cuz I thought there
was more of a balance and this may just
be because the sequels just so over did
it I am but it is compared to definitely
the sequels and compared to films now
it's something where it's like the
matrix is both holds up a little better
but in my opinion a little worse because
well we're doing these dialogues now I'm
like oh Christ this is where all these
other films that talk this was the dual
reaction we had where as I watched the
first matrix with you when we did the NC
and I came out of it I'm like okay this
didn't hold up as well as I thought it
would I still like it overall but yeah I
see what you're saying
meanwhile you for reasons I'll never
comprehend for years was going on about
how reloaded was the superior sequel in
the better movie and then we were
watching reloaded and somewhere in the
middle of all of this dialogue and
nothing happened you just went yeah this
isn't holding up as well as no is like a
total total swingers iced around yes oh
it didn't have the girls now I agree it
is one two three there is one point
because you do bring up a good point
which is the Oracle seems to have
personality Smith to some degree as
personnel I don't like as much as you
claim but at least on until sequels that
I thought was cool about the movie
because you have these humans who are
raised in this computer who are all
computer like and then you have these
computer programs who want to somehow
break free of their programming and
soullessness and they have personality
and I guess that's where I thought it
was fine in the first movie because you
could read into that but then in the
sequels like they never played it up
enough in some cases they over plated
with I made a choice and and I'm gonna
break free and light and that they also
under played it like they didn't make
that the focus and I think you know if
you got throwing all these ideas and
such which I mean it's I think we both
agree the film the first film has a lot
of great ideas
even argue the sequels have great ideas
like they actually do um but if you're
gonna throw in so much talking in so
much detail and try so hard to try to
explain every tiny little thing um
you're already kind of writing yourself
into a corner cuz unless you're unless
you're jr. talking to head you know
appendices up the wazoo of everything it
had everything explained which even then
he had the Hobbit which didn't entirely
connect into the world while you're at
the Hobbit first yeah no but that's why
I mean like it's yeah you're already
buying yourself into a corner because
people are gonna say well wait what
about this we'll wait what about that
what if you're only gonna rely on the
detail area again rely on that the most
you're already kind of dooming yourself
because you had to be detected by the
irrational connect you're right and that
is the proud part of the problem I think
is tone some comic book movies can get
away with giant errors just because you
go into with the tone that was a comic
book maybe this when you start getting
into the Noland films and stuff words
like no this is important this means
something we're going to say is it is
about philosophy and these big idea when
you get into the nitty-gritty details of
it and try to make it very
self-important you can do that I don't
have a problem with that but you do open
yourself up to people looking at it like
okay well then this doesn't make sense
like this doesn't make sense like this
the first film that was my biggest
problem is I still don't understand why
you would have the matrix created and
need people to be sentient I'm like well
they're living off the bioenergy of
humans fine your computers you've
managed to build this super Network
these freakin Cthulhu BOTS running
around with their crazy tentacles plug
people in unplug them why the hell do
you just not take out the part of the
brain that would figure out that you're
in the matrix or give them a lobotomy
and just live off our stupid dead body
like our stupid brain dead bodies oh
that's all my favorite things in the
comments was that if there was about 12
different people that went you know
fool obviously the reason that they have
the matrix is they list a reason and
then the other 12 people list start up
the exact same way
just an entirely different types
everyone has a different reason why
every reason on the planet that's been
given to me it's not in the one of them
none of them makes sense and it's not in
the movie yeah so if you want to justify
it and say well this could be reason why
that's fine you have your theory that's
fine but in Sidi nod movie they don't
explain the film and it's really just
not it's a huge problem for me because
I'm just like why then or when they when
Neil gets unplugged and then he's
flushed down the toilet I'm like why
don't you keep them in whenever somebody
gets out of there instead of flushing
them away why don't you just keep them
in that pod seal it up let them die if
you're where there's people out there
building a Zion why are you yeah no I
know it would you get really all of that
one our super computer major acts like
all that when they're so much if they
didn't put so much focus on all the
details and if there was enough
emotional connection to the double edged
sword where something like Dark City
doesn't give a shit I don't yeah it's
vague which there even is almost a
problem you can look at him be like the
hell is this film even about in the end
it's not here it's here like it is very
vague by but that's a double-edged sword
but but but that's kinda what I liked
about too is that allows you to bring
something to it uh you know well what is
you know it's not I guess not quite
answer but it's raising that question uh
but it's not it's not trying to answer
it for you either that's why I thought
the matrix was it was bringing up
questions but it was trying to answer
them at the same time and I don't know
if that was implicit answered that much
in the first one which is why I like the
first film no no like I said was kind of
trying to like it brings a question but
then it's like maybe it's in this
direction we're trying to point over
here like really over here like really
over we're not saying the answer when I
show you the answer but if you maybe
over there you know it's like alleged as
a comic book style movie that's very
stylistic and bringing up a bunch of
philosophical questions it's an
open-and-shut case of here's a beginning
middle and I think it works fine I think
a lot of the problems the film has is
actually now because it's attached to
the inferior sequels I I don't I've had
issues with it by wilmut I do not I I
don't hate the major I don't hate the
first one a lot of things that we
complain about too was also the first to
do it
know that this ought to do it you know
the head hazards bullet time thing the
style and everything we we grew sick of
it because Hollywood rips itself off
constantly but I mean in 1999 that was
hot shit
I remember being blown away like holy
crap and then by the end of the third
film and they did bullet time for the
180 of time I was like seeing it like
just don't ya know and when people are
like you know how dare you pick on the
effects of course are gonna be dated I
know I really know guys there are very
few effects that can hold up so well
that's like sound so surprisingly held
on yeah there's actually one or two that
are pretty decent but but yeah I get
it's a bet for comedy and B it's more
sort of taking people down and not when
they say it's flawless is what no
there's a lot of problems with it like
there's really problems with any film I
like anybody's saying it's flawless Oh
again go go to youtube there's a lot of
just say the words Keanu Reeves is the
Messiah and tell me that's right
that's always my thing when people can
be like it's a masterpiece it's a grout
dare you not like just Keanu Reeves is
the Messiah and maybe just maybe you
could get away with that and the first
one but as the sequel and a man not for
me I you good for me but do I want to
talk about the sequels and uh uh I don't
have much except that I still think
there's good ideas and highway chase was
cool that's all I took out of the second
one I'm not watching them again like I
said there's it kind of like maybe with
Lucas and the prequels like there's
seeds of good ideas here and some are
even sort of explored a little bit but
somehow it gets lost way too much in its
own being full of itself and being so
detailed and being so Shama Shama lized
and then there was there was the twist
that everybody saw coming that never had
never happened which is you know I'd
what I thought at the end was that they
were still in another matrix that
digital everybody that the matrix was
clever enough to have done a double trap
where they think they're out like when
you have a dream and you think you've
woken up in the dream and you wake up
the third time and realize oh shit I
never gave up and went to work now again
explained like I said he would even
explaining
everything explained all the all the
plot holes and the night as well the
stuff that doesn't makes and the
stupidest thing I ever read was some
people replied with no I mean they
couldn't have done that because that
would have been too obvious and there
and I'm like so what does well be
assessees Jesus so what they went with
with space Jesus was better yes it may
have been obvious but it would have made
sense unlike what they went with which
makes no sense I still can't figure out
I'm like where did he get this power
from you know what actually no after
editing it over and over and over and
watching these goddamn speeches over and
over and over I actually did they did
explain it oh do tell no no okay please
oh so it's the anomaly you know Neos the
anomaly yeah that every time they create
this world there's this perfect one that
can do all these incredible things he
upbeat because of that he has what they
call like a spark of the original
computer energy so that's how he can
connect with them and stuff like that
it's sort of sense to them oh I'm not
saying it makes sense but it is
technically explained so it's not just
he can hold out his hand and and they
disappear cuz he's Jesus is that he has
some connection with the spark or
whatever the same energy that the
machines are made out of so he is I
guess in spirit half-man half-machine if
you plug me into the internet and then
unplug me I can't throw my hand at my
hard drive and turn it on well I didn't
say it makes sense I'm just saying that
it is technically explained in fact
there's a a few jokes I took out because
that cuz when I listen to one of the
speeches I'm like oh and I put together
I'm like okay well that kind of explains
them is okay I'm just gonna take out
some of these jokes just water - as far
as I want your damn good explanation as
I'm concerned that's just saying a
wizard did it that's just magic well
he's got a spark of the original what
yeah nobody there oh I'm not saying it's
good I'm saying that they did explain it
um but it still makes like very little
sense you know but he was half cyborg
maybe and had a Wi-Fi system well I
don't get how it's maybe things cracking
maybe if they x-rayed him and they're
like you have like a half cybertronic
brain or something but then why would
you why would any of them they're all
keep their human ya know and how
can smith hack into an actual mind and
say you know I might take him over
forever what I guess if we want to argue
that there are some machine parts
somewhere in the head if you have to
jack in but they never went into any
detail about that yeah they went into
detail about all these other things but
never quite that so when I and if that's
the case and if there still is something
left and he can control the computers
why can't the matrix reverse that I mean
like hey we know where this asshole is
because he can continue late we've sense
we sense him yeah no I I get breach into
the quiet air stupidest computer ever so
yeah I mean it's that the sequel's I
still think you have some good ideas and
some decent philosophies that do not gel
together at all get way too sidetracked
um you know we're the first one you
could all get sidetracked too but it's
still whenever they go off on a speech
it's still we're talking about the
matrix and the goal is to make you a
better leader even though we're not
really teaching you anything that we're
not just saying over and over and over I
will say this I was surprised because I
was dreading watching the third film
like hardcore I'm just like cuz I
remember sitting in the theater being so
bored particularly the Zion battle this
went on for fucking ever and that
strangely you know if you look for the
silver lining and things I came out of
watching that battle actually way more
impressed with it on the small screen
than I ever did on the big screen how
does your resume than on the big screen
it's a bit of a like jumbled sort of
train wreck on the small screen and we
want you then your TV which is bigger we
watch it on mine which is smaller and I
could make out all the little details
and see how well composed the shots were
and I'm like alright this is really not
only a technical feat but it's really
gorgeous in some scenes like now that I
can see everything I'm not stuck
watching it on a giant 80-foot tall
screen or something it I'm like this
this actually works anyway I actually
enjoyed it now the difference is I had
no connection with a single character
and that was it's failing point because
I'm just like looking at and going wow
this is pretty and oh that's a cool shot
that's a closer but if you're talking
about like getting wrapped up in the
emotion like when the leader of Zion
dies or whatever when freakin Wesley
Crusher
like tries to save the day I could have
cared less which that was another point
we're talking about um in somewhere in
the middle of the battle I remember
turning to you and I was like I just
realized something
in like Return of the Jedi and empower
strikes back in Star Wars you had you
had Porkins you had bigs you had dak uh
uh you know wedge antilles you know and
then unnamed guys I can Jedi in
particular there's a ton of just unnamed
guys I was just like you know to this
day I can remember nearly every single
line those good shot - good shot red -
there's too many of them
I'm had like pancake face yeah like you
know I remember all of these guys and
I'm like I turned you I was just like I
had more motion for people that I had
known for five minutes in one of those
movies Jedi Empire because I think wedge
is really the only one to carry over of
the secondary pilots then I did four
characters that are in the battle of
Zion that had been there either since
the first matrix in second or the second
and I might in these films I think are
longer than Star Wars I'm like that is
spending six seven hours with secondary
characters that I don't give a crap
about how do you do that yeah like how
is that physically I was like return to
the Jedi guy who flies into the executor
and blows it up ah I felt more sorry for
him and his two lines and I did for some
of these characters and I don't know if
it's like a tease character actors know
we talked about this with Brad that
there is something in the 80s and but
particularly the 80s where the the
character's dad knows now lets somehow
even with Nolan yeah it's like all the
side characters in the 80s were played
by really good character actors and
that's not around as much well it
reminded me of a story apparently the
guy who played Porkins in Star Wars was
all upset because he found out his call
sign was Porkins I go I get it cuz I'm
fast what the fuck you know it sounds a
very insulting and Luca Lucas came up to
him and apparently explained that he's
like I know it sounds bad but there's
this whole backstory and he related this
entire backstory to this guy and he
agreed to do it I have no idea if that
story's entirely
I remember reading it somewhere it makes
me wonder if Lucas and other directors
at least in films like that do that with
side characters and are just like yeah
like here's a little back story like a
primer like this is where you come from
I wonder if that informs their
performances at all or if that's just a
coincidence it'll only happen with that
one guy but I feel like no but and maybe
the witch house keys did maybe they're
just not good directors and maybe they
couldn't teach these people how to act
or they suck the life out of them but I
wonder if maybe they just never came up
to these people like this is what your
character is this is your backstory you
got pulled from matrix did this in this
already like it into my Warren any my
guess or maybe they'd ever been so
serious well now I know I took Kerry the
way to me it's like it yeah it can be
either it's just but what whatever it is
yeah like there was something about all
of the pilots in the Star Wars movies
and in other films kind of from the 80s
and early 90s that I got way more
attached to them than I ever Donais T as
stupid as something like Independence
Day is I got more attached to everybody
in that movie than I did in the Matrix
movies like in the battle at the end of
like Independence Day and I'm like you
have to somehow give secondary
characters actual character to make me
care because otherwise it was just
here's a bunch of people just getting
blown up that the let the last thing
I'll say cuz I'm sure we rambled out
enough about this but it's something I
think we both noticed about all the
Matrix films that we it is a really good
thing I so really you don't see that
often maybe more nowadays but definitely
not back then a wide range of races in
that movie like it was your stripy it
was string it yeah there's our white it
was you know which you could argue well
hey fair enough all the Will Smith I
guess was supposed to be the lead how
much better with these movies have been
oh my god Will Smith had been the lead
that would have been a mr. Deveaux of
you've just it'd be so much more
charismatic but like raining bullets I'm
here in New York but yeah like it's you
you look at just like a desire you know
there's like a few more maybe in the
first film but in the second and third
it's like when it's count the white
people there
the two leads or they're the bad guys
like everyone I will note that it's the
two white people that are the most
boring yes so that is something I really
really admired about all the films is
that they weren't like okay let's just
make them all white you know it once in
a while throw into token black person or
Asian princess ability they're all
different ethnicities I really liked
that I thought that was really nice
keeping that variety in their engines
honestly more realistic you know I mean
cuz there are just so many different
I do remember us talking about that I
was like yeah I that was something I
really did appreciate about the movie I
was like well here's a wide range and it
makes sense if you're pulling people
from out the entire world of the matrix
yeah so it's still annoying that it's
still two white leads but I'll take baby
steps and really when it's all said and
done you know it's the old thing about
we were talking about song of the south
it's like yes song in the south is
racist but I will also note that any
child that watches that is way more
interested in Uncle Remus and his
stories and any of those two boring
white keys yes and any other one so
there is an aspect of it that at least
the ethnic characters have actual
character yeah it's very much it well
the same thing we can take out this is
the matrix is our generation song of
those ground breaking effects at the
time even some interesting I guess a yay
did so uh yeah this is pretty much
pretty much our thoughts on the matrix
like I said I mean I I think at been I
like the first movie it's got some
problems but the sequels new having at
best it's okay but I I don't think it
says rewatchable anymore I for me it was
even that rewatchable to begin with
basic school - really funny watching it
yeah I still think the biggest the
biggest sin is that Zion is incredibly
boring whenever they were outside the
matrix see me is that the one is
incredibly boring
yeah but whenever they were outside the
matrix I could have cared less whenever
they're in the matrix and that goes for
the first movie the best scenes in the
first movie are when they're in the
matrix so that's where all the fun is
yeah so yeah it's kind of our real
thoughts on that just us rambling on uh
join us next time this guy is gonna be a
hand
a big slab of angry sushi for Mamma Mia
so we will see you at that one